I'm not sure if you guys saw that video
yeah this the your brother you're not my
brother I'm your brother in humanity
you're not my brother are you a
Muslim how old was Aisha when your
Prophet married her yeah you know in
that very first year on Facebook it had
15 million views wow the very first year
by the way I'm not even sure now we were
walking it was a sidewalk then we saw
this big guy with a with a microphone
with a speaker phone and there were
other guys with all the nasty signs and
then he was yelling nasty things against
our sisters who were wearing the hijab
you know he's like five times bigger
than me right as soon as I went there he
started to look at me with a harsh voice
he said what do you want then I said you
know I'm coming to you as a human I just
want to hear from you what do you have
to say at the end at the end he gave me
5 minute to present The Message of Islam
without interruption wow and then as
they say you know icing Icing on the
Cake he said can we get five copies of
the Quran for myself and then for my
guys he said this yes Allah that's
amazing a lady was was passing by she
stood there and then she saw the
interaction just a random lady and then
she approached she interrupted both me
and that guy and then she said you know
I've been watching you both of you for
the last 5 to 15 minutes if I had to
choose a site I will go with the Muslim
guy what he's saying because the way
that he's conducting
himself
may Allah uny Nots from our tongues
expand for us our chest allow us to
speak the truth forgive us for any slips
or mistakes we make from us and Froman
may Allah allow us to be alone in this
room without the influence ofan may
Allah allow us to be an inspiration for
the Muslim may Allah allow us to conve
Islam in a beautiful manner in which it
will bring the Masters inshallah to the
umah of Islam may Allah allow us to be
leaders for the
righteous welcome back to the realest
podcast in the the three Muslims were're
over here in Chicago Illinois with our
dear brother in Islam the highly
esteemed Dr sail
Ahmed how you doing alhamdulillah
welcome welcome to Chicago it's an honor
alhamdulillah we had you on I think one
of the first few guests we've ever had
on two years ago two years ago virtually
virtually alhamdulillah so now it's a
blessing to be with you alhamdulillah so
um recently
done a lot of work for the D may Allah
bless you and reward you and accept it
from you um spanning from many different
topics many different types of people
very recently with everything that's
happened in Philistine you have taken a
focus to speak to uh you know to Jews
about Zionism about phe about Israel
about what's going on and what else have
you spoken to them
about so the topic is that uh in my
conversation with uh people of different
faiths M I'm focusing more on the Jewish
people based on the situation which is
going on so the topics that I speak to
them you know we speak to them from a
Humanity point of view yeah in my
presentations to them I don't take sides
I don't take obvious sides yeah even
though the subtle message is there
obviously right from the Islamic side
from the quranic from the Palestinian
side I approach them from the side of
humanity mhm and if you approach them
from that aspect you know they don't
become defensive they are receptive to
listen to us yeah so the three topics
which I mentioned to them are these
first and formost that uh how Muslims
and Jews in the past how we live
together for many many decades so I go
over the top 10 points or top 10 um
areas in history how we have done that
second important I go over the
communalities that Islam and Judaism
have Old Testament you know their
scriptures our scriptures our theology
ology their theology so now we are
building bridges with these two points
and now I come towards the action items
that what can we as humans what we can
do to uh do away with the situation and
to do justice and peace it's amazing so
what does that look like so I came back
last weekend from Nashville so in
Nashville we had a Masjid open house so
we have doing many Masjid open houses
and the reason we are doing it is that I
always say to the Muslim leadership if
we don't tell them how would they know
it so I would say that Masjid open
houses is one of the ways we can uh
educate the masses and awaken the masses
see once the masses are awakened
inshallah right that's when the real
change will happen so how does it look
like so mallah many Jews many Hindus are
coming to this presentation I was so
surprised in Nashville like you know
five six Hindu families they came not
only the man the Hindu man came he
brings his wife he brings the children
wow wow and the good news and then then
I'll come back to your question quickly
right is that mallah in this open house
we had many Hindus came many Jews many
Christians and obviously there were many
Muslims too so after listening to the
presentation After experiencing you know
that whole uh uh environment that we
created social activities you know they
had lunch with us and uh activities fun
activities for the children so that
Hindu man and after listening to the
presentation Allah guided him right
afterwards he recited
muhammadh imagine right the situation
has nothing to do with Hindus Allah sent
him over there he listened to The
Message of Islam and of palistine and
then mallah in front of all the people
he declared his Islam wow Subhan Allah
so in those presentations in the
Nashville presentation which I came um
you know last weekend there was a lady
who was the editor
of a major Jewish newspaper wow so she
came not only she's the editor she's the
president of this Jewish Federation so
she came with her mic and with her uh
you know camera with the notepad to
write the notes after listening to the
presentation I approached her so it's on
my TV it's on my channel I approached
her do you agree with those points uh
what do you say about the history that I
presented and she said you know I mean
this is unknown history that nobody from
the synagogues in the public schools in
the churches no one speaks about this so
when we Enlighten them they realize that
you know Islam is not an enemy to them
Muslims and Palestinians we're not their
enemies we are their brothers and
sisters we are their neighbors so that
what that does is it softens their
hearts towards us even doesn't matter if
they are zist or whatever mentality we
want them to first and foremost look at
us as humans M more things in common we
helped each other in humanity inshallah
looking taking that as a template we can
move forward for peace so that's my
Approach amazing amazing So speaking
about the issue in festine what was your
reaction initially when everything
happened well very mixed
reaction uh initial reaction obviously
is that I hope that uh innocent people
are not hurt as a Muslim that should be
our reaction right right no matter which
site and what cause that we have what
weapons and which party initially the
very first thing would be that I hope
and pray that civilians and innocent
people they are not harmed so in my
lecture when people ask me that question
in the Q&A session I mentioned to them
any time when gun violence happens in
Chicago anywhere in the world or any War
happens any attack any bomb happens what
I say to the non-muslims is that my uh
focus goes right right away to the Quran
Surah MAA Ayah number 32 just a
translation The Taking of one innocent
life is like taking the life of all of
humanity and saving one innocent life
it's like saving the life of all
Humanity then I say to my audience over
here Allah is not speaking about the
life of a Muslim any life we have to be
concerned as humans because every life
is equal and precious every soul is
sacred so when we mentioned them that to
the audience they say you know what we
totally agree with you so we need to
make sure that in our discussion when
people are so much polarized we need to
make sure that one of the Arts of
debates or discussions I would say when
there is a contentious issues is to have
them on a common platform start off with
that yeah they feel comfortable
connections are built Rapport is built
and now they would be more receptive to
what we have to say that's amazing so
let's let's take a step after after you
build the report and you you mention all
the points does it ever get to a point
where they're like okay you know maybe I
am Pro pal or maybe I am kind of against
what is
doing so what I do is I present Five
Points which do we have time for this of
course yeah just joking eight hour
podcast
maybe so I present to them Five Points
in this
issue and uh so these are the five
points all right so the very first point
I that I asked them is I mentioned to
them okay raise of hands do any and all
of you agree that every life is equal
and
precious then obviously right everyone
they raise their hands I have tried it
every single
time so that's Point number one so then
I mentioned to them this Ayah from the
Quran Surah MAA Ayah number
32 so the second point I mentioned to
them is okay let's take that as our
foundational point of agreement mhm
that's our premise that every life is
special and equal and uh it's you know
it's equal it's precious then I said to
them Point number two is that means our
condemnation has to be equal any person
who is
compromising hurting compromising taking
innocent life our condemnation has to be
equal if the condemnation is not equal
either we don't agree with premise
number one or we are hypocrites
easy right I mean again we are all
together no Jew no Hindu no I mean no
one should disagree with that point yeah
absolutely logical Point correct Point
number three would be this according to
any international law according to human
conscious according to you know our
Humanity dictates that uh any oppressed
people they have the right to defend
themselves and they have the right to
fight against the oppressors
mhm then I add the point that you know
for that reason bulk of humanity bulk of
all the countries they support Ukraine's
over the
Russians that's the reason you know
people praise Gandhi for his fight
against independence from the British
for that reason the
1776 Revolutionary War people look back
saying you know that's a good fight so
Humanity dictates that uh that
occupiers the occupied people they have
the right to defend and the right to
fight for their freedom no one disagrees
with that yeah and this fighting
involves violence obviously you know um
I think just a quick note on the point
pal people they they tried the peaceful
approach they even tried the legal
approach you know so there's a huge
history going going back there but sorry
not to cut you off no no so those those
are good points so the reason I don't
say too much details in these points
because then people start taking sides
see right now for these points we want
people not to take any sides we want
people to agree with this because if we
bring since so far you may have seen I
have not brought the word festine all
right have not brought the word is I
have not touched upon because as soon as
you do it people take SES so is your
approach more so uh not to interject but
building these foundational five
premises it almost helps the audience
come to the correct side and the correct
unbiased viewpoint on their own true
true because you know when we do dawa
also Mah by three years you guys are all
professionals now Allah make us Allah
bless your efforts I was so excited when
I saw your first podcast and you guys
are doing with so much passion reminds
me when I was young when I used to
follow Dr Zakir n and she ah and you
other I was feeling exactly the same way
the passion is burning with you you wake
up with that you sleep with that you
dream with that right don't you right
that's dawa that's life that's may Allah
preserve it and help us to do more Allah
so so the technique in dawa also is that
based on your question is that you know
people sometimes in their hearts and
minds are so many veils that may uh that
may not let their uh F shine so you have
to remove these Veals from them so let
their Humanity shine let their Humanity
look at the situation so that's what I'm
doing right now let their Humanity look
at this situation in festine so those
are the three points the next two points
are this right so Point number three
what I mention is that every occupied
people they have the right to fight and
defend themselves and point number four
obviously in that defense they have to
make sure that they cannot hurt pinch or
kill innocent people no person disagrees
with that come on who can disagree with
that then I can quote from the Bible
from the Quran old New Testament vas I
can do it right but just by saying
everyone agrees with that point
then I say to them even with that fourth
point there should not be any exceptions
because now if you start taking
exceptions that we can kill this
civilian this collateral damage for that
reason if you start doing it from your
side other side will say the exactly the
same thing yeah so then we should say
there should not be a single exception
to that rule yeah nobody disagrees right
so far yeah then point number Point
number five that's when the action items
are presented by me so the I have again
okay raise off hand do you all think
that we should follow international law
I mean everyone is going to raise their
hand right I mean there has to be some
uh objective
law if you say let's go with the Bible
and may say let's go with the Quran
someone may say let's go with some other
Constitution you know that's going to be
become subjective and people are going
to be divided so I would say to them
okay all those things are important
let's go with something which is
objective that all all the 200 plus
countries they agree with Okay so let's
go with uh uh international law so
international law dictates so now are
the action items for them right for Jews
Christians all the audience
international law
dictates that Collective punishment is a
war
crime absolutely then I will quote them
amnesty and you you know Geneva Carter I
can quote all of them right so that has
to be lifted immediate ceasefire has to
happen
and the blockade has to be lifted MH I'm
not saying it because I'm a you know
Muslim I say to them I'm saying it
because Humanity dictates it I say that
you know international law dictates that
point number two in the action items
would be that uh the right to return of
the refugees and the families mhm who is
saying that the UN resolutions they say
that point number three in the action
item would be that uh every single
settlement is illegal they all have to
go all right yeah not I'm saying it
because I'm a Muslim go to the
international law they are saying it
yeah that it's illegal every single one
of them are illegal illegal they all
have to go
right then I said to them even if uh the
Jews if they were kicked out from any
Muslim country I would fight for the
cause of the Jews for their return to
that Muslim country we have to say that
we have to for as Muslims then I say to
them if Muslims were making illegal
settlements in any country I will fight
on behalf of that country so these
illegal settlements has to
go so we have to give that disclaimer by
the way and the fourth point in this
action items would be that let's have a
neutral party to look at the situation
in the war any party that has committed
any War crime doesn't matter a person a
party a group a president a prime
minister anyone who's guilty of the war
crimes international law dictates that
person has to be punished with the
highest extent of the law MH I'm not
saying it because I'm a Muslim Hindu Jew
Christian international law dictates
that and last important point is okay
fine let's have one country mandated by
the UN every person in there they have
equal
rights if we don't agree with that then
either we are a bigot a racist or we
don't believe in premise number one that
you all agreed with yeah so that's my
Approach amazing how many times have you
given this this talk H since almost day
one from U 7th October wow Subhan Allah
amazing has there ever been any push
back from
anyone um yes uh yes so what happened
was I went to this high school and the
MSA invited me there one of the nearby
High School I gave this talk talk and
there were many Jewish uh leadership
from the Jewish clubs they also sat and
after so not on the pushback was not in
the Q&A official session but one of the
ladies one of the leaders U she
approached me and they said you know hey
what
about I mentioned to them okay let's go
to premise number one if Hamas or anyone
breaking premise number one we have to
condemn them and then we have to uh you
know punish them anyone else from the
other side or any side if they're
breaking that fundamental first premise
we have to do exactly the same thing to
them after that no pushback okay that's
good that's goodd but you guys saw it
right I mean I'm taking the approach
from Humanity point of view yeah their
fitra that they have in their mind in
their
hearts so in this I don't take I don't
use the word festine or
is uh just use the word you know
building up on premise number one
Humanity dictate Ates you know equality
dictates our Consciousness dictates you
know international law dictates and then
I leave it at that I see I see so in
your personal opinion you don't have to
ENT this if you don't want to um there
was a premise you had I think it was
premise number three you said the
occupied have a right to defend
themselves against the occupier um
premise number four then is in their
defense or you know their their fight
against the occupier they are not
allowed to Target innocent civilians
right would you
would you differentiate
between uh let's say's reaction let's
just let's just say for sake of argument
they did innocent men women and children
on the Israel side would you compare
them to Israel in the same light despite
one being the occupied and the other
being the
occupier I mean we can go more into
detail like this in this kind of
questions but at the end of the day we
have to look you know what are Islam's
guidelines yeah and we have to try our
best right to abide by those guidelines
yeah no matter what cause may be the
best cause in the world the whole world
may agree with it even then doesn't
matter which weapon what cause that we
have what Vengeance that we have we
still have to preserve that 100% 100%
yeah because also I say to my audience
that doesn't matter if even if um the
enemy is doing something wrong uh
killing our innocent people ouri
civilians even then Islam does not give
us the permission to go and kill their
civilians yeah that's an amazing Point
100% And um think the farthest we can
really go is just kind of understanding
what could have drove them to such an
extent where they might do something so
so so heinous um or maybe some people
from amongst him would do something so
heinous um I think that is maybe the
farthest we can go but other than that
because context is important obviously
but other than that like you mentioned
we have our values islamically and we
can't give that up for for anything you
know let alone uh an emotional uh
reaction to to any anything even if it
is a massacre so may Allah protect us
and keep us safe um I feel like I'm
asking all questions so I want to open
up the floor for you guys yeah that's a
good way to any
questions on um this is
very mindblowing because it's it really
Taps into the human aspect and disarms
them you know and most people nowadays
they all have a side like you said even
people who have no idea what the
situation is they're going to choose a
side so when you immediately just you
you don't even present a side there is
no side now you're just saying well look
like it's just common sense you're a
human you will want the best for your
own family or people that you love or
people in the community so what about
these humans over here are these humans
over there are these humans here it's
like okay well we're all humans so we
should all have this and I think that's
beautiful now it's just a matter of
practically getting to that point
because a lot of people in this
situation are very emotional you know
like I could speak for myself I could
speak for Ramy I could speak for fed but
if we're talking to someone and we know
like let's say that they
support yeah right and it's like a part
of us is going to feel some type of way
and then we might get overly emotional
or zealous in our speech I've had a very
hard time a very very hard time holding
back with some of these people it's true
though right I mean obviously we are all
humans if don't have emotions then you
know I mean we have to have emotions but
emotions have to be aligned with uh
Islam's guidelines yeah and wisdom has
to be also there you know because Allah
has mentioned in the Quran Surah 16 Ayah
number
125 so we need to always make sure that
our frame of reference is the Quran and
the authentic Sunnah the examples of
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him in
any all situation he used wisdom he used
the soft approach he used commonalities
he used to win their hearts and minds
and not have debates as we see some
debates because now people take sides
people become
defensive and once that happens we
cannot touch their hearts and Minds
because eventually we want to pull them
to our side we cannot do it if we have
that other approach compared to the
Islamic the prophetic approach yeah so
how do you remain cool and collected in
these situ situations that can get
very emotionally charged yeah take a lot
of Xanax before you go
there don't do that that could actually
work then you cannot even do da you'll
be like sleepy the whole time yeah and
you're you're a medical uh doctor right
so that was a
joke yeah all right no prescription for
anyone all right so that's really
important uh because uh our state of
mind when we approach anyone uh should
be the state of mind that how would
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam How would how would he have
behaved if he were in that situation so
once we have that frame of reference
like really solid in our heart and mind
uh that will be an easy way for us to uh
stay calm and to be Collective uh and
secondly would be that obviously we
cannot have a mentality of defeating
them mentality but meaning their hearts
and mind mentality should be there you
know Islam is so true we can defeat any
person any time right with we have the
truth
alhamdulillah but in the sake of
defeating if you lose the person's heart
and mind you know what's the point of
having that 2hour debate with that
person point number two right Point
number three is when we look at even
from the Quran in Surah and uh in which
M Alam when he was sent to F the Tyrant
of there not to go and Shout at him and
debate with him be soft with
him if the one of the greatest Prophet
ever in the history of humanity facing
the one of the greatest tyrant in the
history of humanity Allah is commanding
M Alam to be soft yeah that's an amazing
are we right I mean so these thoughts
when they are in our mind before we go
and during our conversation that will
help us insh in Collective yeah I really
love that last point because mam I think
it's fair to say he was a Prophet who is
very like Stern you know
maybe forgive me if I overset but maybe
a little hot tempered in some cases so
it's even more significant I think Allah
told him that um in that moment yeah
yeah so you know so these are some of
the things because if these uh important
points these Concepts if they don't
become our frame of reference then our
uh emotions comes into play then the
person their past uh videos comes into
play you know we are thinking that you
know this person is against us anyway
sometimes the environment you know like
if you're in the Speaker's Corner you're
supposed to behave this way comes into
play some other times you know let's
have more views when we having that
debate comes into play but none of them
are important I mean they are important
perhaps but at the end of the day you
know our uh uh our evaluation on the day
of judgment is depending upon how close
how how aligned that you are to the
Quran and the prophetic sunah that's
that's what counts at the end of the day
so on that note um obviously you
mentioned the beautiful in the Quran
Allah he tells us to call to the way of
Allah with with with hi with um with
wisdom is there any is there ever any
time in which anger is actually good or
maybe necessary because you know
obviously there are Hadi that describe
the prophet as getting very angry
sometimes when other people's rights
were taken away or other people were
oppressed you would get angry to the
point where a vein would pop from his
head so is is anger ever a a a necessary
and important tool and discussion I mean
anger is important anger is a to um it's
an emotion that Allah has given to us uh
we have to show anger but the anger has
to be channeled in proper action and
proper guidelines yeah so we just cannot
be angry and you know break down the
windows of McDonald's that matter right
I mean yeah I mean you know we see that
in I shouldn't say fortunately
unfortunately but that's a reality so
that's a anger that uh we need to
channel properly so anger has to be
shown if you don't show anger I mean we
are not humans yeah if you cannot show
anger against somebody who's getting
raped I mean come on I cannot say I'm a
man if I don't get angry and do
something to it yeah some people are
getting B children our may Allah protect
all of us right all civilians all over
the world if you don't show anger and
just be on our phones and social media
come on we have to be angry but Channel
it properly that's when we can see the
results because for the sake of anger if
you're angry right blood pressure is
going to go up our health is going to
compromise uh we cannot be productive
and then we may do things that we may
regret not only that we may do things
may God you know forgive us that we may
do things that may not be aligned with
the Quran and the Sunnah so anger is
important but we need to channel that
anger and the prophet he used to do that
aldah ald this reminds me of mentioned
that the strong believer is not the one
that can physically over power the other
believer but the one that can control
his anger you know at times of being
very emotional and riled up it's a good
reminder Mah alhamdulillah and this this
reminds me of this book by Sheikh Mikel
Ahmed Smith with the heart and mind and
he talks about the the moral and the
emotional intelligence of the prophet
and goes into how there were times where
he would be expected to behave you know
and let his emotions get the best of him
but he didn't he always had the utmost
perfect conduct you know perfect char
character um and speaking of books
honestly there's been uh couple books on
the list that we wanted to talk about
today alhamdulillah I don't know what
camera angle can can go into these so
these are some of uh Dr sail ahmed's
works right now alhamdulillah so the
first book we have over here is top 50
dawa projects you want to talk about
this book yeah alhamdulillah it's a
commercial
break so this one the reason I wrote
this book it says the top 50 dawa
projects that any person any family any
can do so I I so I went to Dallas and we
were having this you know conversation
with the brothers up there and one of
the brothers he was a physician and he
mentioned in the in the discussion you
know brother sail you know I am a
physician he said that you know I don't
have enough time I want to do something
I maybe have two hours a week I want to
do something what can I do other people
were approaching in a similar way then I
went then I came back home and I thought
you know what people they want to do
something so let's pull together the
dawa projects that I personally may have
done since the last whatever 20 25 years
and that was uh the purpose of writing
this book is to let people know that
even if you have one hour of time a week
you know two hours a month for example
even if you're just doing it personally
just individually or in the platform of
a Majid they literally unlimited number
of projects that anyone can do so I pull
together the top 50 and and um not only
I mentioned the dawa projects suppose if
one of you would like to do one dawa
project right then I broke down that daa
project into like all the steps how many
resources are needed how much funding is
needed how much time is needed how do
you start how do you finish what are the
pro trips tips regarding it so a person
so I made it as practical as possible
not like on the clouds okay dawa is
important we know that how do we do it
on the ground every single one of them
has that same template Subhan
Allah may Allah preserve you and Elevate
you and rank for this just going to go
over some of the quick ones uh you know
and I highly recommend you guys get this
book inshallah where can they get this
book at by the way if you go to
amazon.com just type my name sabil Ahmed
okay inshallah so some of these they say
prison Outreach campus Outreach uh a
youth version of daa literature write
articles for the Muslim media virtual
reality glasses so they're very creative
too and I like that a lot of them are
more applicable and relevant to today's
day and age in the technology
technological uh I guess Advanced day
and age it's not just stuff old fashion
and out ofd because unfortunately a lot
of the old ways of uh being literate in
media are outdated today so if you don't
keep up with the times unfortunately
your Outreach and and influence as a
might not be as efficient as it could be
so it's absolutely important that we try
to adapt and and and almost I get it you
know the technological age of a lot of
brothers and sisters watching watching
especially the older brothers and
sisters unfortunately uh might be a
little difficult you know but it's it's
going to be worthwhile inshallah if your
intention is for the sake of Allah to
really have as much influence as you can
even that's why as we started YouTube
you know a lot of people might be
wondering like why do you guys care
about you know this thumbnail being this
way or the title being this way the
copywriting these things matter if you
really want your videos to have more
reach we can't just you know do
something subpar and leave it at that
you know marketing and and these things
really do matter so
for this so going back again to that
book maybe one of you can ask me this
question okay there are top 50 dawa
projects which one do you think Dr seil
you rank as number one which one would
would that be one of your questions
maybe of course 100% that's question
would you be curious I am I'm very
curious is it smiling H is it smiling no
smiling is not a DA project smiling is
smiling is a state of mind it's not a
project that you do you know 2 hours 2
p.m. to 400 p.m. on Sunday M that's a
that should be part of us anyway
correct uh my number one da project of
that top 50 da projects would be Masjid
open
houses and you do a lot of these yes so
can you go a little bit into what these
in tell sure sure so a Masjid open house
in which we invite our fellow Americans
or fellow Canadians fellow you know
non-muslims we invite them in the Masjid
and we create an environment in which
they can feel that you know they are in
a safe place they connect with the
Muslims we eat with them they they have
social activities they watch the Google
Glasses right they're Blown Away by that
by the way the Google Glasses um
calligraphy try a hijab for the ladies
the H thing for the girls and for the
ladies so we create an environment in
which it's a it's a fun environment they
connect with the Muslim shaking hand
smiling
hugging so they feel uh safe right and
they feel accepted and they feel
welcomed their perception that they have
about the Quran and about Islam about
the Muslim especially it goes away so Dr
sail how do you even get them get their
foot in the door how do you invite them
into this because one might argue
getting these non-muslims to get into
the MJ seems rather difficult sure sure
I will come to that really quickly right
so I'm just bringing the concept of the
open houses see uh in the USA a typical
non-muslim they have taken in the Pew
research survey that a typical
non-muslim if they have not met a Muslim
they have a negative perception about
Muslim
78%
78% but if they meet a Muslim that
negative perception goes down to about
28% look at the stock difference right
so just meeting a person does away with
fear of the unknown of that person
Subhan Allah so that's one benefit of
having this Masjid open houses the
second benefit is that um of any project
that I have
seen in can you name me any project in
which a person 200 non-muslim sitting up
there and now pin drop silence for half
an hour they're listening to The Message
of Islam you can never replicate this
any other place at the job you can you
cannot do it uh at a neighbor you cannot
do it the da boot people are in a hurry
but now people are receptive just
imagine for half an hour you can tell
them anything that you
want and then with all of these social
activities and the approach that we take
in how to present Islam in this Masjid
open houses now they become receptive to
the message and now we give them a time
to ask any question that they
want one of the top questions is okay
what is Jihad you know polygamy for
example and Sharia and this current
situation that we're going through so
now we want their hearts and Minds to be
open we don't want their questions to be
you know taken back with their homes
without getting them answered
so before they come and by the time they
leave we want them to have positive
feelings about Islam and Muslims and the
Quran right so that's the benefit of the
open
house so now your question is how do we
bring them inside yeah I need to know
this right so on the website of gain
peace we have a tab we have a tab about
services and in there we have a to z how
to run a successful Masjid open house so
anyone can go to the gain peace.com
website and uh then we have the whole
you know PDF document so we have a
checklist of items that we uh that we
use for marketing literally our team
they go house to house knocking at the
door like 1,000 people for example right
that's one way second way we have this
postcards with invitation that we send
out to like 5,000 people the neighbors
then we go churches and the synagogues
then we have a team that uh also calls
the media you know that Jewish lady who
came uh with the who was the editor I
personally invited I personally called
her on her phone that we are doing this
it's a way to build the bridges and to
see how we can live as Neighbors in
peace and Harmony she came along with
her family right uh we send out these
postcards to the children to give to
your teachers in your public
schools we give it to the male person
who comes in there the post man who
comes up there the Uber driver we give
it to them we give it to the Amazon
driver we want to exhaust any and every
single way then we have the yard signs
we have a big poster in front of the
Masjid right Masjid open houses so
anything that you can think of social
media obviously we boost so we use any
and all of these That's when people come
in
alhamdulillah first I think that's
amazing Allah bless you I think inshah
everyone should check out your book
because that's just one idea you know
imagine the other 49 that are in there
Allah so I think that's in something
that T3 might work on doing in the
future um open house um at the Masjid
inallah uh so one question I have is how
can we use these open houses once we get
the non-muslims in to Enlighten them you
know my advice to every single Masjid
there are 3,000 mids Plus in the USA not
sure about other countries but at least
over here every single Masjid should
open their doors every day we should
open the door every month every week let
the non-muslims come in our brothers and
sisters in humanity so that's how we can
uh let them know the true
narrative what uh what we say what we
think what they need to know see we how
do they how would they know if you don't
tell them yeah we can have all the Ries
in the world all the protest in the
world right we can write all the letters
to the Senators the Congress and all the
presidents we can do all of that but we
need to awaken the masses how do we
reach out to the masses yes you can
reach out to the masses by your
colleagues your classmates your
neighbors but imagine 200 people coming
there now they are exposed educated with
our narrative imagine if 3,000 plus
massages if they do it every week every
month it's going to be a total change in
the country so these open houses I would
say bottom of my heart right encouraging
every single Ma and we can help you guys
we have the template we have the posters
we have the Flyers we have the whole
Logistics work out amazing so along with
all the amazing things that things are
people are doing continue that include
this in there inshallah it will be
really impactful inshallah inshallah so
if anyone wants to get started on this
Amazing Project you can pick up the book
get get the steps online um and uh
inshallah just go to the local M and
start it up right that's gain peace.com
and you'll find the resources there in
the
website with that being that was moment
right there with that being said my
question to you I'm sure you've seen on
the online space
some of the dies that get overly
emotional about these things and it's
almost as if they are trying to prove a
point and trying to almost make the
other person seem wrong what are your
thoughts on this and how can one avoid
that completely of course of course uh
as I mentioned right
uh our attitudes cannot be that we are
better we want to defeat you yes we can
defeat them but then we may lose the
person the person may not be listening
to what we have to say not only that you
know the thousands of people who are
going to watch later on that video of
that interaction that debate they may
think you know what these people they're
just going to shout and yell at each
other and debate with each other those
people may have a not the right
perception about Islam Christianity or
whoever the opponents are and generally
in faith itself number three would be
that
um I mean we have to look at the way
that the prophet sallallah Ali wasallam
how he used to you know conduct himself
so dawa the default way of dawa is not
debate the default way of dawa is to
approach with compassion with empathy
with kindness winning their hearts and
Minds uh so that's the approach for dawa
right so what a incident comes to my
mind as Hamza has reminded us that
you know that big guy who approached me
at that time I'm not sure if you guys
saw that video yeah this was the video
right yeah yeah you know in that very
first year aldah on Facebook it had 15
million views
wow on the very first year by the way
I'm not even sure now it's been long
time um so in that interaction of mine
with that
person a lady was passing by she stood
there and then she saw the interaction
and just a random lady and then she
approached she interrupted both me and
that guy and then she said you know I've
have been watching you both of you for
the last 5 to 15 minutes if I had to
choose a site I will go with the Muslim
guy what he's saying because the way
that he's conducting himself Subhan
Allah W and what even happened in that
altercation for the people that don't
know that's all right so what happened
was this was a ikna nna convention this
was in Washington DC 2019 I believe so I
was coming from my hotel with my family
right my kids my wife and my family we
are going to the convention uh because
one of my lectures was about to start so
we were walking it was a sidewalk then
we saw this big guy with a with a
microph with a speaker phone and there
were other guys with all the nasty signs
and then he was yelling nasty things uh
against our sisters who were wearing the
hijab he was saying wrong things and
everyone was shouting at him right all
the Muslims they were getting emotional
they were shouting at him you know go
back don't do this then I said you know
to my um to one of the brothers you know
what open the camera start the recording
I'm going to approach that guy you know
he's like five times bigger than me
right and the reason I got a bit Brave
in there is because there were like 200
cops standing up there there were like
500 Muslims standing up there right
looking at what's going on and then my
wife was there as my bodyguard all right
so I said uh fine let me interact with
this guy as soon as I went there he
started to look at me with a harsh voice
he said what do you want then I said you
know I'm coming to you as a human I just
want to hear from you what do you have
to say then let's have a conversation
nice calm conversation so I listen to
him then I presented our point you know
rationally from the scripturally
historically comparative religion voice
at the end of the time he started to
tone down a little bit I'm not sure if
you were there he started to tone down
and that at the the end at the end he
gave me 5 minute to present The Message
of Islam without interruption wow and
then as they say you know icing Icing on
the Cake he said can we get five copies
of the Quran for myself and then for my
gu he said this
yes that's amazing whatever intention
that guy has doesn't matter at the end
of the day as long as he listened to
what Islam is that 5 minute he cannot
complain on the day of judgment that no
one told me about Islam wow so no matter
what intention what tone that they have
what you know signs that they have the
way that I appro that I approach that
person is Allah sent that person to me
there subh we actually had something
similar not you know aggressive
altercation you know fortunately or
unfortunately depending on the lens that
you look at in but today we drove from
St Louis in Missouri all the way to
Chicago now anho since you did obviously
most of the talking in this podcast I
want you to continue that in why don't
you tell the viewers a little bit of a
of a synopsis or a rundown what happened
in the mjid when we were making woodo
bro and we stopped in like what the most
random place in Illinois we didn't even
know the mid there yeah so I saw a
brother saw a man okay and saw he was
making W do but I saw he kept like
looking up at the sign they had a sign
that showed how to make the W the steps
of how to do it so I was like oh like
it's a re you know like masah you're a
Reaver too yeah alhamdulillah so I I
asked I was like brother like are you a
Reaver and he looked back he's like no
and I was like so like do you know what
you're doing and he's like oh I'm
cleaning myself I'm like but you know
what it's called right and then we
started like talking more but he started
saying that he believes in God believes
that there's only one God but he's not
really religious he just kind of accepts
all religions and he says from his from
his mouth he says that they're all true
he says that uh there's many ways to go
about the same message and that it's all
leading to the same place and so we try
to reason with him and try to speak
about certain things all of us at the
same time all of us different like
oneon-one
and for the most part like he was kind
of I won't say
unreceptive but it was like
circles you know like they there was no
grounding and so at the end I just told
him listen like if you truly want to
know the answer just you know ask
sincerely to God like for guidance yeah
and you will be guided you will yeah
inshallah you will find the way but like
you can go to every single person you
can ask all these people but you have to
go to the
source and and uh I I just want to know
how would you handle that
situation no Mah that's really good that
you're observing right so that's really
important that any place that we are
especially in public we have to observe
what people are seeing and doing and
behaving acting
interacting uh so that's a important uh
you know way that we need to conduct
ourself and not just be on the phone if
you're sitting in the lobby of a
doctor's office or somewhere else right
so we have to be aware
of the environment uh secondly if I were
in your situation I may be doing exactly
what you you what you have done addition
to that one of the techniques that I use
is that we need to make that person
agree with us with some
premise so once we are on the common
platform that's when we can bring that
person in this
direction so what I would have said to
that person is whatever his name right
let's say Jonathan okay you know
Jonathan you are saying that you know
all the faiths are fine no M all the
faiths are true all the scriptures are
true all the roads read lead to the same
destination is that what you're saying
and he would say yes correct is that
what he is coming from okay fine then
then I would have him come to this
common flat okay so Jonathan do you
agree with me that any ideology need to
have some
guidelines suppose if there no guidel
lines if anyone can say and behave and
act any which way that you do and call
it a faith would you accept
that that makes him think then I will
add him this question okay suppose if
some group makes up a faith an ideology
that it's okay to harm children and
sacrifice the children and they write a
book and they have their own church or
whatever place of worship and they call
that as Xyz Faith would you also accept
that Faith to be equally true true as
the faith of Islam Christianity Judaism
he has to say no if he says yes then he
has to reevaluate all the faith that
he's saying is all
right so I would take that approach to
make him think then I will give him the
criteria okay fine so we agree that
every faith has to have some guidelines
so all the faiths cannot be true at the
same times because they contradict with
each other in some of the main Concepts
like for example when I am conversing
with a person from the bah faith I as
them the question you know you take a
Bible to be true and Quran to be true
both cannot be true at the same time
either both of them are wrong or one of
them is Right both cannot be right
because if the Bible hints towards
crucifixion Quran denies crucifixion if
the Bible hints towards Jesus peace be
upon him as the Son of God Quran denies
it if the Bible hints towards Trinity
the Quran denies that both cannot be
true at the same time absolutely yeah so
I will take that Direction ultimately
the the reason I'm having these points
with him is to for him to agree that all
faiths cannot be true there have to be
some conditions for the truth of a faith
once he comes on that line of thinking
that's when you can give some conditions
of what makes a true Faith yeah yeah the
problem was though is
that initially he would agree initially
he would say yes there is one God and
then out don't know he would just switch
it up and then out of nowhere he was
saying oh no well look I believe there's
one guy but then I believe that there's
another God on top of him and it's the
same God and it's God 2.0 I'm
like what are you saying yeah it got to
a point where we just had to kind of
like walk away he said many different
things he started with saying that uh
nothing is true or we can't know
anything is true and then he said
everything is true and then he said all
religion is true then he said well only
just like these ones and then he was
like um it's Blind Faith I'm like okay
I'm I'm going to walk away buddy but but
even for that
person I may listen to that person but I
will take from him you know five minutes
okay this is what you're saying Jonathan
please listen to what we say about Islam
so then you give the basic concepts the
fundamentals of Islam so at least on the
day of judgment he cannot deny that dawa
has not been done to them right so what
are those points that I will give it to
them first and foremost the concept ofed
the concept of who Allah is who God is
secondly uh sorry how do you how do you
even break that down for
them
um well I mean I let them know that this
is what Islam says and for each one of
the concepts then we can break it down
for them okay you know for the concept
of god let's break it down uh between
what Islam says about the concept of God
versus uh Christianity Judaism and
Hinduism for example okay then I let
them know that why Islam is concept of
concept of God is true even if you look
from our own uh logical rational point
of view that it's not contradictory all
the prophets they came to preach that
concept even Jesus peace be upon him
that was his fundamental you know uh way
that he wants to educate his people
right the second point would be that all
scriptures cannot be true and one of the
conditions for his true scripture is
that it has to be
preserved yeah and then you go and break
it down and then show that Quran is the
only scripture then point number three I
say to them is in this Four Points of
dawa is that uh if so Humanity needs
complete comprehensive guidance yeah how
to run a political system economic
system Judiciary System social system
educational system right so we give them
a list then we ask them the question
okay give me one faith we need it and we
need a faith to satisfy all of these you
know uh ways to run Society Hinduism
does not do it neither does Christianity
or Judaism Islam is the only faith that
gives complete comprehensive practical
beneficial guidance and workable
guidance by the way we need it Nobody
Does It Islam does it so Islam gets a
check mark again so you you almost bring
them to the conclusion that the only
rational I guess conclusion you can have
to satisfy all these criteria is Islam
so you don't really go out of your way
to refute other texts or stuff like that
yeah so we are not refuting we are just
showing that why Islam is true in
comparing and contrasting not from a
scriptural point of view but from a
rational logical point of view yeah you
have a very principal discussion with
them so first one would be the concept
of God then the purity of the scriptures
then the comprehensive guidance Islam
provides and the last one the concept of
salvation alhamdulillah amazing okay so
now here's a big question and this is
just something that me and F spoke in UA
uh a while back I think in the beginning
of the year and you know how you said
basically if on the day of judgment he
can't say that he didn't receive the
message right so would you say there's a
difference between
hearing or reading the message
versus receiving the message like
internalizing it and then knowing that
ah this is the truth you know because
someone could hear it but then they
don't internalize it do you do you mean
from like a Salvation point of view like
on the day of judgment on the day of
judgment yeah like can they be blamed or
not can they be blamed or not somebody
just who let's say presents them the
truth they don't even pay it any mind
versus someone who actually internalizes
the truth yeah yeah so both are
important because a person may be just
casually watching a video about Islam
you know drinking whatever drinking
eating socializing but you know maybe
just receiving 20% of what what the
person is saying on the video so that
person may not be 100% uh understanding
the
message right he may be just listening
it may be just white noise to him but he
may not be understanding the concepts so
obviously on the day of judgment Allah
subh is going to take the whole picture
MH into context and judge that person
and also Allah T may also judge a Muslim
to see how effectively the person may
have conveyed the message Subhan Allah
right so we also would be taken into
account that okay fine we had the
knowledge and we had the obligation to
gain education and we had the the skills
and the blessings to properly package it
we had the example of the prophetic
Sunnah to control our emotions and
channel it have you tried from your side
okay fine they will be held accountable
for their deficiencies what about you me
as a sail me as a Muslim wow so it works
on both sides Subhan amazing yeah that's
that's amazing Point Allah bless you I
mean it's it's even more important for
us I think cuz you know we're at da
Channel or whatever you want to call us
you know um so may keep us sincere
steadfast and allow us to give that in
the best way um the last question I have
for you Dr seil is um I I imagine
there's a lot of people at home who
don't see themselves at the very
beginning doing Meed open houses or
going to like a Speaker's Corner or
going to a DA Booth or starting a
podcast based on on Muslims or Islam
What can the average person do to get
started you know giving dawa you know to
maybe their peers or colleagues or
family if their family isn't Muslim sure
sure so how can we start in a simple way
right uh so we have a Muslim brother in
Chicago obviously I will not name the
names so he's not a speaker he doesn't
have skills so Allah gave him the
passion for dawa when he speaks so let
me just say that his IQ maybe is 80 all
right which is a Reality by the way
right he has passion for dawa much more
than me I would say right he has passion
for dawa you know when we look at him me
and my friends we always joke you know
on the day of judgment Allah is not
going to hold him accountable at all
after he dies day of Resurrection
straight into J F that's the passion he
has so he's not able to speak properly
and what not the only thing he does is
he gives me a call saying you know Dr
sabil I'm going to this Walmart have to
do da up there or to this shopping
center can you give me 10 or 100
brochures and he goes there just with a
simple smile not speaking any word he
just pass it on pass it on that's all he
does Subhan Allah so it's almost like
everyone has a different strength or
weakness what I'm saying is that every
one of us we can do something we can at
least converse with our colleagues and
neighbors and classmates even if you
don't have that much knowledge just give
them some websites even if you don't
want to speak speak give give them some
brochure mhm but as we doing this then
try to on the simultaneously try to gain
knowledge fill in the gaps that we have
if we want to enhance our uh speaking
and communication skills there are so
many classes that we can take if you
want to develop our writing skills video
editing skills I would say that this is
the most resourceful generation in the
history of humanity so every single one
of us we should become a specialist in
at least one field of Islam one field of
Da no one can be like a simple common
Abdullah on the ground we have that
ability we have the
resources Allah's help is there with us
what I'm saying is every one of us we
can do something 100% guys we don't want
to see no average Abdullah on the street
after this podcast but in all
seriousness uh Dr sabil the messenger
ofam did tell us did he not that convey
from me even if it's one Ayah yes and if
you can't do that then just AK your
character your manner this is absolutely
important um just treat every
interaction like it could be your last
because you don't know you know
sometimes we have audacity thinking we
have a whole life ahead of us to achieve
XYZ build this establish that but we
don't know if that one interaction when
maybe you're a little bit hot-headed and
maybe you project it maybe what if
that's your last you know we don't know
and that non-muslim might judge you for
that you know and judge Islam
unfortunately based on your actions as a
as a Believer 100% a couple of books you
want to quickly show maybe of course
yeah yeah yeah so we got two books
before we wrap it up so the first one uh
onel do you want to do you want to
pronounce this second one is OMG it's so
easy to share Islam and do you want to
go into this inah yes alhamdulillah so
this book was authored by my daughter
all right I don't think you guys are
married yet we are all of
us I don't married to dawa I mean
married to okay no I'm
just um so it's important so you guys
have children not yet no none of us not
yet okay fine so plan ahead now that as
you have children how to extract the
talents that they have how to use it for
dawa so mallah my daughter she's really
good in um animation in illustrations
and writing allahar so from the second
second fourth grade I gave her this
assignment in one summer so when she was
sixth grade I said Zab in this summer I
want you to write a book because now she
has attended many open houses many like
now she is a pro in you know how to do
da right so I said you know when you go
to any children's bookstore Muslim store
the books about Dua about how to pray
how to respect parents all of those
books we need those right not a single
book how kids should have confidence in
Islam package the message and Shar the
Islam confidently with non-muslims so
this is a story book in which a young
girl Sara
they went with their family to Six Flags
I think somewhere some car over there
looking at the hijab this islamophobic
guy comes and verbally attacks her so as
he does it she remains calm and
Collective and confidently she defends
herself and her younger brother so this
is that story to such an extent that he
becomes interested in Islam and he
approaches her parents and they say you
know what your daughter does such a
amazing job of explaining what Islam is
I want to read the
Quran so then she goes over this
technique of OMG High technique right
you know the technique o stands for
Oneness of Allah m stands for Messengers
G stands for guidance from the Quran and
the Sunnah so om G High hi I the H
stands for the Hereafter if they agree
with om g h now you I for invite wow wow
that's the reason you see OMG it is so
easy to share Islam Subhan Allah
right Allah bless you guys brothers and
sisters watching uh this book authored
by Dr s ahmed's daughter um so this work
from him and his daughter may Allah
preserve them immensely for this and
Grant them the highest levels of Jenna
for all of their contributions this book
over here is something that you guys
want to get for sure as he mentioned for
the expecting parents and the parents
right now it's never too late even if
you feel like you know you haven't
really been on Dean most of your life
and you haven't raised your daughters
and sons to the best of your ability we
can't turn back the clock obviously even
if they're a little bit older and
teenagers and the time is now you know
it's never too late and inshallah you
can you know learn a thing or two from
this book and uh the last book inshallah
we're going to bring up today uh is
going to be Allah made us Perfect boys
and girls s explains Islam and
lgtv so do we want to talk about uh we
don't want to get uh banned from YouTube
so the lgtv electronics movement
unfortunately has been uh taking power
and strength uh unfortunately over the
public schooling system so do you want
to go into this book yeah so this book
um is the latest book it just came out
two days ago wow all right alhamdulillah
so the reason um me and my family my
children we all wrote this book together
so this is a story book to let the
Muslim children they know that what does
Islam says about this topic because they
hear about this topic in the public
school on the social media right even if
they go outside on the street they see
all of these flags and whatnot so we so
if you go to Amazon there are so many
books about from the other side in
different languages literally hundreds
of books but from the our side for our
children our families zero books Subhan
Allah we are concerned about it we worry
about our children but every single U
you know Muslim uh should be able to you
know not only say what is right what is
wrong but there should be books there
should be contents there should be you
know videos especially for the younger
ones because the other side is getting
the young ones as young as Like
Preschool ones right and brainwashing so
it's important that us as Muslims we
should we should be content
developers so that's when we can say our
emotions have to be channeled into
action so that's the slogan we can use
right let our emotions be channeled into
proper positive proactive prophetic
actions and this is one of the humble
Works may Allah accept it so there's the
first and the only book for the Muslim
children on this topic so we are in the
process of making a series right Sarah
explains about this topic Sarah explains
about Islam on that other book Sarah
explains about who Jesus is s Ali
wasallam s explains about Ramadan so we
want to have a series and all the
parents up there mallah Allah has
blessed all of you extract the talent
identify the talent put this into you
know proper way how that Talent from
your kids can assist Islam can assist
dawa erase the misconceptions at the end
of the day our children would be having
a mission in life which is to eloquently
positively confidently share The Message
of Islam with humanity and guys I just
want you to look at the the
illustrations and Subhan Allah the depth
of relatability over here for the
average child watching it's something
that it's it's very easily digestible
it's not something that's complex we
I've never seen books like these so of
course we have the clear Quran
translated by Dr mustfa kab for kids uh
with I think there's like images and
stuff like that but I've never seen like
dawa manuals for kids so this was this
was phenomenal may Allah bless you guys
for your
work so anold do you have you a
question who we're going to wrap up soon
inshah I wanted to ask a question but I
think you were saying that we spoke
about this when we did the virtual
podcast but go ahead not everyone may
have listened at that time yeah you're
correct you correct any question go
ahead so the question I had is when we
were talking off the camera you had said
that for you you decided that you wanted
to do da fulltime when you were younger
you said 17 right yeah maybe younger
maybe even younger than this yeah okay
and so what did that look like for you
cuz I know you said at some point you
were practicing like as a
doctor
and you know you made the decision but
it didn't all happen immediately but you
started to practice you started to
actually give daa and then it just
became a moment where you were able to
let go of the medicine and then go
straight into the da 100% like what did
that look like for you yeah please pleas
going into this I know it's a little bit
unconventional we're doing the
introduction about your journey at the
end in the conclusion but by all means
for anyone that doesn't know about your
md background and all that right so by
education I have an MD background also
by education I have a PhD in Islamic
Studies alhamdulillah right um all right
so what was my journey quickly all right
because it's a long journey so my
parents mallah may Allah bless them
reward them J all of our parents right
all the Muslims Mah um so they used to
bring this uh Islamic videos almost
every day and they used to watch and
they used to invite me and my siblings
come and watch with us alhamdulillah
right every parents desire is like that
our children should be well grounded in
knowledge so sometimes I used to
sometimes if I have homework and um
video games right I was Aver a child but
one day they said you know sail we
brought this video we want you to come
and watch this even if if you have a
final exam please come and watch with us
sub alhamdulillah as a good child I came
out and I watched the video it was a one
hour video after watching that video
that one hour was the life changing one
hour of my whole life that was
it subh that was it and that was uh what
was it video perhaps that yeah yeah so
that was a video of Ahmed he was having
a symposium with one
Pastor who converted to Islam MH his
name was Gary Miller mhm so this video
was in South Africa it was a big Stadium
right thousands of people sitting up
there so the way with confidence Ahmed
he was explaining Islam with passion I
mean have you guys seen his videos of
course right I'll be disappointed if if
you didn't alhamdulillah so with passion
and with confidence and with evidence
not only he was sharing Islam but the
way he was taking the question MH so me
as a young boy at that time you know
just like all of us as as we we were
young we used to believe that Islam is
just uh you know we are Muslims because
we are born into Muslim families uh
Islam is one of the face of many other
faiths and we used to just have a
circular reasoning Islam is true because
our parents are telling Islam is true
but that one hour made that whole
difference to me because now I realize
Islam is true not because I'm a Muslim
by birth Islam is true because it has
evidence to it wow strong evidence to it
so I had that passion now I know that
Islam is true now I want to be like that
man on the video Subhan
Allah we all have these turning points I
think for brother Ramy over here Allah
me reward you rewinding a few years not
too long ago back to his journey he had
a video coming across you know I think
about El and that video was your Turning
Point do you want to quickly go into
that yeah it was I want to hear it
alhamdulillah it's it's a little
unconventional the topics that that kind
of motivate me towards Islam but the
first video was about um I went to a
Catholic school and I think a year
before watching this video we sat in
like the Bible study class and they were
talking about you know Satan how he's a
fallen angel and all that stuff and all
I knew was that that didn't make sense
in Islam that's all I knew that the
angels in Islam they don't disobey Allah
that's how he created them without any
free will or free free choice they do
whatever Allah says so for me when I saw
this video about Islam it spoke about it
just for some reason resonated very well
with me and the way the IM was speaking
the way he conveyed the story it it was
beautiful and then he goes on to talk
about how and this is why it's a bit
unconventional um how we might not be
the only uh existence um that Allah has
created or what we know might not be all
there is um in one Ayah he said is that
Allah he says in the Quran that um he
created us um and kind of put us above
most Creations so like we know we're
above the animals the best of us are
above the the angels we know we're above
the Gin so like what else is there
that's created that you know we're not
above so it it's just interesting so I'm
like you know this is interesting so I
started learning St more video to video
to video to video and um lots of debates
she Ahmed was was amongst the the people
I listened to who inspired me and then
eventually um I listen to the stories of
the prophets and when I got to the S of
the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam I
was crying balling my ala by the end of
it and that's when I had this moment I'm
like I need to dedicate the rest of my
life to this religion absolutely bro
like my my turning point to be brief you
know is I saw the debate from AA you
know the old I think uh she hortus used
to be a part of aaya now he's part of
sapiens and he did a debate with the
atheist Professor Lawrence
Krauss and this was like one of the
first experiences of me having exposure
to a Muslim who's actually you know
intelligent Aluma using science and
refuting the atheist for me growing up
you know in the west I think we're
almost all programmed in this atheistic
education system unfortunately in public
school so when I watched this video I
had a preconceived notion you can either
be smart and sciency or a Muslim and I
thought they were mutually exclusive
unfortunately so when I saw this I was
like Subhan Allah the intellectual
fortitude that you know sheor had this
is what was my turning point and led me
into you know the whole Islamic Dios
spere like this side of YouTube did not
even exist to me at that point and then
once you watch you know obviously now we
have merciful servant one message
Foundation all these things in the
algorithm but before that I had nothing
so for me Allah used this video to you
know Channel my turning point and it was
around the time I met Ramy and then I've
been knowing on H for quite a while now
uh but at that point alhamdulillah he
took a shahada and he became a Muslim
alhamdulillah and then we decided to
start the podcast
so every anold do you have a story you
want to share about your turning point
or
no actually in regards to this point no
because it wasn't like how you guys were
mine
wasn't uh watching a video or something
like
that you make it you make it sound like
yours was a little bit more juicy you
want to go into that no no no I I'm not
trying to take any Spotlight or anything
like that I'm for too tired to even go
into it it's it's again it's like
different you know like the context so I
think with you three like it was it was
all on point yeah and you have the whole
rever story on your on your own personal
YouTube channel right so for anyone uh
interested in that inshallah please uh
check that out is there anything else
you Brothers want to go over before we
wrap it up I think that's good inshallah
inshallah Dr sail may Allah bless you
immensely for all of your contributions
in dawa you are definitely
uh a force in the da you've inspired
many du up until now is there any
take-home final messages that you want
to leave with the Muslim brothers and
sisters that you know maybe lack a
little bit of empowerment think that you
know who am I I'm just you know an
average Abdullah I don't have any
influence I can't really change anything
Allah's already decided you know I don't
really know much about Islam you know
well the take-home message alhamdulillah
reminder to me all three of you and all
of us would
be that the mission the greatest mission
that every single Prophet had was none
other than dawa no Prophet is to come
now we are those ones that Allah wants
us to share the message you know angels
are not going to come down yeah knock at
the door of the non-muslims and say
Quran is for you that job is for
us so every single person mallah with
the time with your ability if you don't
even cannot do anything at all donate
your money to dawa for those people who
are doing it
and the second and the last important
point would be that
uh calibrate our emotions our dawa
techniques about dawa
packaging to the prophetic Sunnah and
the Quran obviously control our emotions
have a Purify neara not for the YouTube
view not to have more views and whatnot
yes we need more views anyway of course
Allah will give Baraka to us inshallah
have the proper uh have the purity of
our intentions and have the right
methodology of the Quran and the Sunnah
the results are not in our hand we will
not be judged on the day of judgment
based on the results but our intentions
and our actions so may Allah give us the
ability to take that as the mission in
our life to convey the message and may
Allah soften the hearts of the people
around us using hikma may Allah subhana
tala open the doors for all of us amen I
mean guys just so you guys know like
it's literally 12:52 a.m. right now
we've stretched this podcast you know uh
Dr sail Ahmed we were supposed to meet
him today at 5:00 P p.m and things
happen inshah so may Allah bless you I
don't want to stretch this podcast uh
too much longer but final question this
you're talking about sincer sincerity
and Our intention in our Nia how do we
actively renew this and how do we
maintain this at the Forefront of our
minds as
du so what I do almost every prayer
almost every Dua after every you know
sitting down after every prayer many
times every day I pray to Allah oh
Allah keep my knee up pure take away the
pride from my heart let not be let me
not be arrogant and let me be always uh
look into the Quran and the Sunnah the
way that I act so try to do this many
many times because you know uh when you
look at maybe your comment sections in
your YouTube videos people may be
praising you guys right wonderful job
Young D mashallah you know they're doing
good sometimes uh these comments get the
best of us so each time when somebody
does that to me I change the topic to
that person right one way or some other
time I just said may Allah make me
better than what the person is saying
and always mention that you know may
Allah put us on the ground right not not
up there yeah so constantly um praying
for the purity of the
N constantly right I mean just don't
pray one time and that you're not you're
done for the whole year MH so constantly
checking our Nia I think that's one of
the best ways right I don't think we got
to the the point that anho was asking
about how you left medicine and all that
did we well I mean U so the important
reason is that one of the scholars I
invited him to my home for lunch or
dinner and he asked me that same
question that how come brother sail that
she left medicine and became a
full-time I mentioned to him that in the
USA there are 700,000
Physicians and then just a handful of
full-time diesis when the need is there
not in the medical site but in the
Islamic dawa side so from the common
sense way it makes sense that there
should be more Muslims and becoming
full-time
dies because I don't want to U regret on
the day of judgment or I don't want I
don't want to regret on my death bed
that why didn't I do more when the need
was
there that thought got the best of me I
said you know what Allah is going to
Help Me Guide
Me Allah Mah is doing that Allah anyone
can be a physician but not everyone can
be a DI but everyone should be a DI
right before physician yeah so I'm not
saying to anyone out there leave your
profession and you know just be on the
road homeless and become a full-time die
Allah would give Baraka inshah right
however whatever profession that you
have you still have to do dawa yeah so
by default every Muslim should do dawa
no matter what profession no profession
that they have so it's a obligation for
everyone but there should be many
Muslims who should join Daw is fulltime
right because we cannot just complain
about islamophobia and their ignorance
and whatnot if we not if we have not
educated them yeah so we have to do our
job and then whatever happens it is
between them and Allah but we need
sustenance right so how does this
full-time di pay the
bills oh how do they pay the bills many
different ways right many different ways
um have a money plant at
home um so some people they can write
books and that can be their sustainance
some people they should become speakers
and people should fund it some people
they can make a dawa centers uh and then
when they show the work and have the
impact the donors will come to you right
some people they can approach uh some
big organizations and they can say you
know what these are my skills my
experience my knowledge do you have any
openings so there are many different
ways that you can explore uh to have the
financial sustainance
in and Allah will put put Bara in the
efforts if you have the right near and
uh the right methodology inshallah Allah
will open the doors
okay bless you immensely alhamdulillah
it's late so forgive me if I sound tired
but may Allah allow us to renew our
intentions keep us sincere accept from
us our good deeds and grant us the
highest
Lev bless you so much for joining us and
thank you so much um you know for the
work that you do I know you don't like
being praised so in I'll keep it simple
may Allah bless you for the work that
you do and uh everyone watching at home
if you made it towards the end please
share it with um everyone anyone since
that was an obligation it's important
that everyone hears this message
inshallah please make do out for us and
dril may Allah bless him immensely we'll
see you guys in the next
[Music]
one